this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block an especially
great place to get Italian food inside
of your body and you can go to 1811 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles on the way to
the beach great block pizza get that
hitter what's your favorite space a
circle na square space this episode is
sponsored brought to you by Squarespace
from web sites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business if you're still using
word of mouth man you might want to shut
it down
get that Squarespace its award-winning
24/7 customer service you got a question
they've got answers it's simple to also
set up your domains and transfer them
all over to Squarespace it's never been
easier you can sell products you can
manage inventory do what you need to do
for your business go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com slash
Theo von th EO vo in to save 10% off
that's that discount for your first
purchase of a website or a domain that
squarespace.com slash Theo von carrying
a wallet in the back ear pocket in your
back pocket what set for stealing
somebody can easily steal from you are
you poor now could have been because
that's what you were doing but
everything can change in a moment and
that change is the ridge wallet the
ridge wallet is that front pocket carry
and it has a beautiful tendency to hold
everything you want and be able to be
put in the front of your pocket why keep
this stuff why keep your your gold and
your silver in your you know in all your
you know quality metals behind you keep
them in front of you where you can hold
things and also this thing bullet bullet
might be able to this might be able to
stop a bullet
I'm not saying definitely you know don't
have your cousin hold it up or your step
wife hold it up and shoot her but just
take care of yourselves out there and
get the
Ridge wallet go-to Ridge wallet dot-com
/ Theo to get 10% off of this beautiful
piece and also while you're there they
got this beautiful knife here that click
that's the knife baby so look if
somebody does take your money now you
got this beautiful accoutrement shave
chase them down and get them right you
know get them right get them tight Ridge
wallet comm slash Theo
for 10% off these Ridge wallet front
pocket hitters and this beautiful knife
today's guest is a comedian host he's an
entertainer he's an entrepreneur
he's somebody that for me it has put
race you know he gave me a man I don't
you know I come from one area of the
world with different types of racial
stuff and this dude comes out of a whole
nother pocket then I never thought about
and never even knew existed
so it's definitely you know a
conversation that that is you know
making my mind reach around you know and
touch itself and he is from another
country could be you know we'll see
looks could be deceiving you know he's
that bok choi bad boy you know he's that
karate hotstepper bruh it is from just
kidding news and his new movie [ __ ] I
think it's called her [ __ ] house mr.
David self
[Music]
so you are and I'm not trying to start
with ethnicity or anything but like if I
look at you I noticed that you are from
somewhere I'm not saying you're Korean
yep
do you feel Korean does it feel like
when you get up in the morning do you
feel because like I just feel white
probably you know you know that's so
interesting cuz like I grew up in like
Sacramento California right there's not
that big of a Korean community there
okay and my parents they ran and owned
still to this day a black beach supply
store
so predominately people that I grew up
around were black Wow yeah I mean so I
like a whole identity crisis as a kid
because I was a korean-american and I
was even born in Korea Wow but so you
were like a bot you were like a kind of
like made in America straight up you
know even though I came here when I was
two so you know you were made in Korea
yeah I'm I'm gonna immigrant you are
straight up like I came a citizen like
eight years and then you got an urban
haircare right when you got here and did
you like where did you use a lot of like
urban haircare products you know I
didn't I could see with a finger wave I
was I will say this though I did do a
lot of nails for no goddamn reason
really cuz you know that was the only
[ __ ] I was a little kid my parents had
me work at this store since I was like
three years old oh and you guys did
nails there as well no we didn't do now
as we sold nail polish so because we saw
abuse apply to a lot of like other
barber shops and nail stores
oh so you would put the nail see you
would do my mom's nails that's cool mean
as gangster as possible we want one side
red on the other edges battle each other
[ __ ] hard man it's not as easy as
people think really I would try to do
this [ __ ] would piss me off because my
you know a little OCD is [ __ ] I couldn't
do it right so can't do it right till
this day Wow man yeah dude this is so
cool because we have we have I'm trying
to think of you know everything
everybody's so into like diversity these
days and so you know and and so some of
that started to make me feel like
sometimes about like my circle of
friends and what it's like and like the
people that I work with and it does make
me think like on the road when I
I do comedy shows no like I want to have
you know I'd like to have a little bit
of diversity in my lineup
you know we're instead of it always just
being like you know why before that I
just it was like a white guy that was
usually the opener for me or what worked
with you know not the opener that sounds
like you don't that topic of diversity
like I you know I understand it's like
the hot topic right now right you know
there's always people that go a little
too extreme left or too extreme right
like we got to be diverse well they have
to be dope too right and what they do
right so a lot of the times like I see
like force diversity you're talking
about there's a lot of force diversity
you know and a lot of people who are a
vocal that I know that you know they're
not my friends but I know of them
they're like you know they're not giving
me a chance I was like giving you a
chance for what you suck right you know
I feel like you have to be good at what
you do first right you can't just like
jump in the pool and expect everybody to
think like oh I should give you a chance
just because you're Asian now and that's
the hot topic right be good at what you
do first right I'm saying like Saudi so
as so as so as of do you feel like a
minority or not no I mean it's hard to
say men like that one of the lessons
that I learned especially doing JK news
was then my bubble was really small so
you know I would say stuff like what's
with all these like Asian kids
complaining about like you know why
people bullying them and [ __ ] I'm like I
never happened but what I didn't realize
was that Sacramento is like one of the
most diverse cities in the world
yeah sacrum when you get up to
Sacramento San Jose San Jose is like I
you don't even know who is anything like
it's so diverse and like when you get
into some of that area it's extremely
diverse yeah and even like people in LA
they say LA is diverse but not really
there's a lot of cultures here but
people don't mix right they don't
San Jose Sacramento everybody mixes like
no group of friends there's black people
Indian people white people whatever you
know right so like that's what I grew up
with so I thought that was a universal
truth for everybody but it's not the
case right so you know that that racism
stuff that happened it you know it did
happen but didn't really happen much and
if usually if you said some races get
your ass beat so right but not everybody
had my upbringing so I had to realize
like oh [ __ ] like people still get
called ching chong and you know people
still pull their eyes back you know
wherever they're from right which didn't
really happen much here and the only
time somebody ever called me a [ __ ]
wasn't when a black girl come here check
it out that's a little weird
makes you feel funny inside how dare you
know I remember like whenever you know
they had a room
there was an Asian kid near us and I'm
talking about this story we went to try
and see him you know and he wasn't there
and it was just a pizza that it burned
down and like the roof the roof that
interests you unique roof or whatever on
the ground people thought that that was
like an Asian you know UFO or something
that man you know cuz if it's out of
that unique roof yeah and that was now
on the ground the building is gone so
there was like rumors started that
Asians who lived there the Asian people
owned that Pizza Hut no there were no
Asians at all it was it was just bad
Intel okay but but the crazy thing was
like that's how you know and then after
that later on they had an Asian kid in
our high school who was like we were
super white though you know he seemed
super white was he fit amis um was he I
feel like if it's like Louisiana he was
been in me there's a lot of hitting me
now there's a ton of Vietnamese in
Louisiana yeah you know and now like I
try to sell uh so years ago with this
these girls called wink event planners
and they were Vietnamese wedding
planners and I thought it was the best
show ever it was like they put on these
big southern decadent weddings and it
was these beautiful Vietnamese girls and
these young Vietnamese guys and we
couldn't sell the show but but it was uh
I learned really quick like what that
kind of culture is like and they worked
together a lot they love to work and
they love to like like barter and
communicating like paper [ __ ] in cash
and [ __ ] they got a little bit of
gangster and I'm like it was you know
now it's a lot more diverse I think in a
lot of places and if you don't want
diversity these days you kind of it's
almost like you have to status cities
yeah you know even then like when I was
in Louisiana I was not what's that place
with all the titties and [ __ ] the French
Quarter yeah yep so I was there right
and then all the titty you know that is
[ __ ] Wow yeah it's what I'm talking
about like on a Tuesday it's poppin and
I had no idea cuz I got flown out there
to do some kind of brand deal [ __ ] and I
was out there and even the way the dudes
try to get you to come into their strip
clubs was a little too forward for me
like I walk by and this guy came up and
you'll excuse me I'm like what's up he
goes you like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
kind of intro like I was like I do but
no thank you but like even then like
salad first samurai like a bread basket
like warm me up a little bit just be
coming at me like that but when I was
there uh it was with me and my friend
Eddie was my video guy and we were
shooting something from them right
by this guy just drove by the truck he
was like [ __ ] chinks and you know
like I never experienced that so I'm not
on is it I'm more like that was dope
like I've never had that said to me
before you know it was like a new
experience I was like holy [ __ ] Bell's a
drive-by racing shooting like this was
crazy
it's like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what it
feels like it kind of burned my chest a
little bit like a fine whiskey um so but
no I think you know what's funny is when
you say that you know I bet there's some
like probably some really hell of rural
people that is drove into the city just
to do that they saw me come by they're
like I've been waiting for this oh dude
they probably got a hotel room for the
weekend you know some guy in his buddy
or guy and his wife they're like oh
we're gonna get up there and really use
use some of these racial slurs we've
been saving up yo bet that French
Quarter area is kind of like Vegas like
nobody's really from that area there's
no everybody's from everywhere there you
know what I mean so you can't really
like say those are like Louisiana
people's right there just from all over
the states yeah so when I was kind of
surprised like this is Vegas yeah it's
like Vegas it's straight-up Vegas it's
like a dirty kind of Vegas like it's a
little bit of free piss everywhere but
yeah we like and I don't mean to get
into every tip but you know what one
thing I found that was interesting
and so David so is a comedian and you
worked as a youth minister yeah is that
right yeah and I just think everything
about you did you make me laugh so hard
when I was on Jackie dude you were like
them one of the funniest people I've
ever been around and I was like who is
this guy and everybody there was great
but um but but yeah man I was just like
I gotta I gotta get to spend some time
with this guy I said thanks so much for
coming by no man like you were like one
of those guests that came on JK news and
well I hope you got to get this guy back
you know because Jay King he was like we
kind of just said whatever the [ __ ] you
want dude you were that's what I noticed
you guys like white people we are living
in this weird place of fear that that I
don't think is very real sometimes but
then I went to and I was like oh god I'm
after really mom up he's in Q's and you
the Jake you know they say whatever they
want yeah and that's the thing to us
sometimes people get on us they're like
what you guys say a lot of races [ __ ] I
thought we say races [ __ ] about
everybody yes you know what I mean
because we're just making like
observations about cultures because we
grew up in a very diverse area
yeah so we're not coming at anybody
particular we're just talking about
these little things that we've seen
growing up you know so when people are
like what you say so many bad things
about Asian I say bad things about
everything you know I mean you can't be
racist when you hate everybody
yeah I don't believe in like this whole
like I think everybody's be able to
everybody's disgusting yeah you know I
just got to pick it out you know
so when you came on like when we
literally tell guests like say whatever
and if you feel weird about it we'll
take it out right but but don't be
afraid to be yourself and we're going to
be smart about what you say too so if we
say like mmm the people might not
perceive this - well we'll take it out
in the editing right you know just
because like we want to be smart about
what we're saying and what you're saying
but don't be afraid to be yourself
ya know no matter what you say it's not
gonna be as bad - what Bart says that
guy said some crazy [ __ ]
yeah he's wild huh you know put a
picture of himself on the toilet
yesterday I think Jesus par get it
together your part has his ongoing thing
where you know he likes to like troll
people hmm so he has a kid now so he
just says a lot of pedophile [ __ ] you
know people he's a pedophile he's a
rapist I think he's doing that too
because you guys keep saying it I mean
but you know people are a little slow
yeah yeah yeah he's interesting man yeah
and there he is right there Bart Kwan
and Mark Kwan is uh he he and his wife
run a gym and they have a sweet couple
and they you know they're fun to be
around because it's like need hearing
about their like kind of marriage life
and stuff like that and they have a
little baby that's beautiful little kid
but yeah so you guys this group is kind
of different so and for people I don't
know about JK news it is can you explain
it to him real quick
JK news is just basically a show where
we talk about current events but it's
not really about the current event it's
about the conversation right you know so
we just says we just kind of I think our
motto is like real news just real er
opinions mm-hmm that's really what it is
we're just stating like random [ __ ]
so sometimes people come on the channel
they're like why aren't you talking
about the article that's not what we're
about right just sparks conversation and
so for us when we first started out
people were very particular they're like
we want to hear more the story well
[ __ ] go [ __ ] read it there it's
called just kidding news what were you
expecting they were CNN you know what I
mean like well your facts are wrong I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ]
that's what people don't really like I
literally don't know [ __ ] yeah there's
like we say we there's a group so you
take me real quick - the the the group
and it's a diverse group you have
do you have we have Mexicans and Chinese
people and Korean and Japanese yeah okay
so that's that's that verse man yeah and
then for me anyway yeah and then we
always try to bring other people's
perspective we try to get like white
people on black people on and oh it's so
awesome man yeah I was like [ __ ] this is
what it feels like to be free like you
guys it felt like I just felt free over
there yeah man and the cool thing is
it's like well the bad thing for us like
no brands want to [ __ ] with us cuz we
kind of like talked too much
mm you know which kind of sucks cuz like
I've been trying to get a McDonald
sponsorship for days there and they just
I think they know because they keep
sponsoring all my friends around me I
think it's [ __ ] with me now at this
point it's not so different KFC you guys
can't get them you know KFC I don't know
what I can t KFC so I really what would
happen have food poisoning once when I
was 14 haven't touched it since from KFC
can't touch it and that powers a lot of
your you know a lot of Asians are
powered by KFC if you got a lot of Asian
countries there they Korean people love
Cobra Shanghai China every building has
KFC in it dude there was and also they
have like they'll have the smallest
McDonald's they would they had an 8
square foot McDonald's dude you couldn't
go in it was just a window outside of a
thing but there was one person in there
there was like nah dude they had a
[ __ ] grill next to him that a shake
maker they had [ __ ] Happy Meals is
they had another little Asian person on
a shelf making a people's toys literally
making them right there cuz they're it's
China you know it's like they had some
like dude I'm not joking there was a
drive-through window
but there's no way to get you guys had
to walk up to it and it was eight square
feet and it was one person running a
[ __ ] McDonald's all by themselves
you know you know what's crazy like when
you go to other countries that's outside
of like America or even like European
countries right my Asian people have
this like addiction to working hard yes
I don't know what it is but when I went
to Japan and I went to their McDonald's
like that's the definition of fast food
I ordered the food right I go number one
bla bla bla bla and they go okay thank
you and I walk two steps and it was
right in front of me wow the whole I'll
say this mine they like that stores I
mean this is fast food yeah this is what
it is
and that guy was sweating and working
his ass off as if he owned the company
yes yeah but they give it well they have
pride there's a different amount of
pride that comes in a in places that
I've been in Asia there's a different
matter of pride that comes even and
they had like you were at the hotel and
if you had a question you would ask
somebody and then they a lot of people
need jobs in China so they they have a
job and they want that person's job to
be of use and so then like oh you need
to go talk to this person even if they
knew the answer it was like oh this
person is in charge of that you need to
go talk to them even if that person was
10 feet away from they would walk you
over to that person then you stand there
and talk to that person and you know the
other person could have answered your
question yeah but it's like everybody
has a job and you walk outside of the
hotelling's it's somebody's job just to
kind of tell you hello and see how
things are going and like but and there
were security guards in the weirdest
play here yeah like there's like a tree
right here you know like you don't China
you need China's kind of dangerous to me
man like really that's like one of those
spots there's a couple of places that I
know that people are from that they
never want to go back to mmm like Maya I
had a bunch of Indian friends in college
right and I remember like I was talking
to his dad I was like you all the left
goes in go to India he's like goodbye
hey don't ever go bro like you like I
know you don't want me to go he goes
it's terrible it's just like what
literally Toby he goes have you seen
Aladdin he goes just like that that was
a joke there's a lot of people wishing
here we get better yeah you know I'll
just kind of like surprise I was like
damn like he really doesn't want me to
go to India you know but like a few my
friends that have gone they said that
you know I mean obviously the nice air
is always nice but he goes like it's
super impoverished so it's not it's not
a real depiction of what you think it is
right you know I mean there's a lot of
like kids who were were poor homeless
like begging on the streets and I don't
know if I could emotionally deal with
that yeah it's like who wants to be fed
yeah you know like it's not like that
it's not like that um Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire that get rid of it what was
that movie Slumdog Millionaire that's a
good movie you know Americans have this
weird fascination or it's not Americans
but at a certain level of wealth which
America is automatically at even just by
being in America we have his fascination
with seeing poverty yeah and that that
is like a tourist thing in a way I don't
think we even realize it you know but
for us to see poverty like an extreme
level it's um or to see like a third
world country to see something like that
it's
and now I'm kind of thinking about this
as I'm saying it it's that's something
that's something there I don't know what
it is that's true because my girlfriend
always asked me she goes how come you
don't want to go to Europe plus I'm not
trying to see it's too comfortable I
wanted I want to feel scared yeah I want
to walk into a country and wonder if I'm
a walk away with my [ __ ] passport for
some reason I like that like I want to
go there and I want to feel I want to
feel something yeah that's interesting I
never thought about that [ __ ] but I'm
trying to go to impoverished countries
yeah huh yeah and I think it's also it
makes you feel something like I remember
going like in a South Africa and going
to something like these uh Soweto
villages and stuff like that and it's
just I mean it's hundreds of thousands
of people living in Lee you know just
lean to things that you would something
you would see like you know and I don't
mean the center fence away something you
would see a dog living in you know like
in a poor neighborhood America see a dog
kind of lean and you know and like a
makeshift kind of dog and you know you
have whole families living in these and
then just tens and thousands of them on
top of each other and uh and there's
something it does to you it like I don't
know if we if seeing that makes us feel
more you know grateful for what we have
our mate but it's it's almost yeah I
don't know what it is I mean I'm just
trying to think about it it's
interesting you know traveling's like
something one of those things that I got
into later in life you know when I was a
kid you know you kind of grow up with
not so much traveling isn't really an
option like I only knew about traveling
like to me like traveling was like some
white people [ __ ] yeah here I mean like
I would travel you know to the other
side of the city and that's about it
yeah I don't know where now was in
college right and like it was something
small as this like I would talk to you
know there's a lot of white people in
college where I grew up I didn't have a
lot of white people so they would say
[ __ ] like oh yeah I'm going on vacation
I'm like the [ __ ] is that
yeah yeah what's vacations like where
you take a break and you've got a break
what the [ __ ] is that what are you
saying to me right now you know out of
here and so what I didn't realize is
like that kind of stuff is important
because it opens up your world because I
lived in this small bubble I mean I
thought everybody was like me biggest
things Sacramento you know like the use
of the n-word right everybody used that
[ __ ] growing up I can remember the very
first time I used it to the guy who
taught me how to use it yeah you know
and when I went to college I didn't
realize that not everybody is okay with
that right
you know just because for us it was a
term of endearment it was how you got
angry sad whatever was how we joked with
each other yeah when I went to college I
was like oh [ __ ] I can't just use it so
freely you know say oh this is a
ffensive ass turn right you know what I
mean yet as some people and it's
sometimes I mean it's offensive on like
in the immediate Stephan like portrait
you know like but just in certain
instances some people don't mind as much
you know it's like it's weird it's like
some cultures like smaller subcultures
you can kind of use it in like I
remember when I was in when I was in
middle school they had this group called
NFL and it was the N word for life that
was our little group right and him it
was like a mix kid in there black and
white couple black kids I was the white
kid in it and it would definitely like
in our little group or five or six kids
it was okay yeah at certain times now
dude if that group one together bruh you
weren't [ __ ] even try and pretend
like you could say that exactly so it's
it's definitely different in certain
little pockets here and there but what's
interesting to me is so a lot of people
would think oh well white people are
always using this term and like racist
redneck white people but then it's
interesting to hear that there's a group
of kids in Sacramento who are using this
term growing Asian Mexicans everybody
man and it's it's it's weird because
like one people I was like trying to
explain it to somebody once because they
didn't grow up brown a single black
person ever right right and they're like
well you use it in front of your friends
and stuff so can you use it for nothing
no like the black card doesn't have this
this transfer it's like your California
license yeah I mean it only works in
California yeah if I go somewhere else
it doesn't apply you know so you got to
be very smart about it or in the case of
just know who's comfortable with it and
there's even people like in the black
community who don't like the word at all
yeah they won't use it yeah so it's not
like something that's just like you know
no pun intended black and white right
you know I didn't mean and so for me I
just try to steer away from it as much
as possible every now and then just to
be honest like it slips out when I go
back to Sacramento cuz everybody's
singing in front of me yeah you know
what I mean so I mean but that
sacramental bubble so I have to realize
that's not the rest of the world so I'm
just trying to be smart about it just
you don't gotta use it bro yeah you'll
have to just try to take it out your
vocabulary the best as you can
I mean I've been using I was a little
kid yeah I use it in a positive way but
that's
doesn't mean that's how everybody's
gonna perceive it so I just had to be
smart about it yeah yeah a nice
especially even having a southern accent
have to be careful because it's like
immediately people think you know
suddenly they put me on a farm and hit
me beating families and like that and
it's like it's [ __ ] up kind of you
know it's like you know it's uh but I
think it's I don't know it's interesting
man it's definitely it's uh it's
interesting to see that just because you
grow up in a place that it has a lot of
diversity that still you can see it as a
bubble because that's really the truth
of it
the truth of it is is that we had
bubbles you know like we had a bunch of
kids growing up with a head lisp for
some reason i grew up in like the enlist
belt and so you had a lot of lists so
here's the thing dude if lisps you were
welcomed by us brah you know i'm saying
yeah we grew up in the [ __ ] list belt
you could have all the lists you want
everybody knew how to deal with some of
the list it was welcome we would joke
around about it it was comfortable list
people were comfortable non list NL's
you know we're comfortable Ike it was
okay so then it's interesting because
that's our little bubble when you go
into somewhere else and you say maybe
somebody had a lisp and you said
something back to him or joked around
and it wouldn't be you know it wouldn't
be kind of the same it's just what I'm
saying it's just interesting how but how
I could go to a really diverse place
that was head of to bunch of different
ethnicities but maybe no lisps and then
suddenly like it you know what I was
comfortable back in a place where I'm
helicopter around people lists subtle
and like I use a term and other people
get nervous but they don't know that
like yeah it's okay in this bubble you
know kind of interesting too in that
case cuz for me like you know what I
found out about myself under what the
college was you know the stereotype is
is like if you have somebody like the
very negative bad stereotype is like if
when you're in front of like a group of
black people people feel uncomfortable
but for me I grew up around there so
ever I feels comfortable right but when
I was in front of a group of white
people
I felt I feel weird oh wow I was like
these [ __ ] are judging me I
could see that you know I mean I was
like oh [ __ ] and it felt [ __ ] odd and
I wasn't used to it and specifically
like I call it like white humor you know
I mean like I didn't understand a white
humor so they would bust jokes I'm
sitting I'm the only one not laughing I
didn't get it mmm
some white people [ __ ] so why don't went
to college that [ __ ] was like national
Geographics for me I was just observing
people in the bush you know look at the
way they high-five it's way different ya
know there's they don't do that they
just touch it they walk away you know in
my batch I get in with these groups like
it was like a wild thing to me man
yeah and so like even like greetings
jokes like even white people food you
know I mean like I know why people like
hamburgers and [ __ ] but like I was so
ignorant like I remember I talked to my
friend Kail
I was like yo Kail what do why people
eat what do you mean I was like you know
aside from like hamburgers hot dogs he
goes no casseroles yeah
is that casseroles where you take stuff
in the fridge and then you just put
whatever and it's why it's white paia
it's like the white yeah what is it what
is it called an Asian culture white rice
it's fried rice it's white people fried
rice I was like oh [ __ ] that's your
fried rice and I started collecting [ __ ]
I said what we do is we take our chicken
feet and we chop the [ __ ] and we throw
that you know we throw like random [ __ ]
in there that's why like when I watched
what's that show that Joe Rogan used to
be on as the host fear factor uh-huh
that [ __ ] used to crack me up do my
agent people must luck how do people
feel about fear factor in the rating
question it's just lunch yeah they would
be up there they would just be like like
Joe Rogan's like you have to eat [ __ ]
bull balls and my parents are like
that's pretty good you know and there's
nobody scared ya the fighters are like I
wonder what recipes they're gonna like
though you would never see an Asian
person on fear factor dude cuz it was
just a normal Sunday you know any baby
they're like you have to cross this
river swim and then survive I'm like
that's how I came here anyway ya know
the Delta is flooding yeah that's it wow
man it's so crazy like if somebody has
to bring up a clip of just like a legit
Asian person being on fear factor
because that's nothing it's almost like
I'm faking it huh they're either faking
or they think they're just recreating
their life how they got here like Joe
Romo you gotta build this boat and go
across and save that person that was me
let you me you know just go over swim
you know like it was so funny oh is this
it no I reminds me of Tyrone Biggums and
uh
Chappelle yeah he handled everything he
was a homeless crack addict and he
handled everything on fear factor and
this is Rogan on the show no oh yeah
Rogan played himself on the show
but he he eats a yeah a buffalo penis no
problem he's like oh I get an extra free
meal that's exactly what that [ __ ] was
because they would talk about stuff on
fear factor as if it was something
nobody has ever eaten but I grew up
eating that [ __ ] right like this oh yeah
dude and when I was in Shanghai even I
mean I know that's China and it's not
Korea but it's like the things they had
like in a gas station as snacks yeah the
things they sold on a train as snacks it
was like Talon like animal Talon
hawk or some kind of hawk or maybe a you
know a strong strong Sparrow you know
pigeon could have been a [ __ ] pigeon
with like you know like a you know kind
of cleft palates in its feet or
something but like huge talons with like
in a barbecue sauce or and a gaunt like
it was like what and you'd see some
[ __ ] kid just sucking on the toenails
I mean like [ __ ] this is an important
thing to talk about too so some people
here like what is he saying is like you
can't say [ __ ] that Bo cuz he went there
yeah there you know what I mean so I
like for me it's like you say it I'm
like that [ __ ] so true yeah cuz like
when I went to me that's so scary right
yeah but then also like I grew up eating
crawfish so if you see somebody and
you're not familiar with it and even the
Vietnamese people said I'm putting you
know just general but Vietnamese people
love crawfish I got some big thing in
their culture right but it's like seeing
somebody eat something different than
you do it's sometimes it's [ __ ]
baffling man yeah even for me like
there's something I can't eat that a lot
of Asian people eat it's a tripe which
is like that inner lining of a cow's
stomach [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] but Asian
people eat that [ __ ] like it's a
delicacy now like I swear like our
people are so dope because in the sense
of we whatever why people thought was
trash Asian people are like that's
delicious you know I mean it's almost
like what the [ __ ] is going on right now
man and we eat why people eat cracklins
which is basically like we'll fry up
pork fat right yeah so it's kind of like
it's not the same as tripe me you guys
are going way deeper than the fat like
cutting the stomach out after which i
think is bizarre but asian people don't
like to waste things oh absolutely
they don't like to waste things at all
well why is that I think it's just like
it's survival you know what I mean it's
I feel like a lot of Asian people are
it's about utility too you know what I
mean like if you look at my house my
bike every Korean or like
zero generation or first generation home
has a house that doesn't make sense like
this is a bunch of you know like I feel
like this is what I saw growing up was
like whenever I went to like a white
person's house their furnitures matched
you know what I mean there's a purpose
for this and you know what I mean and
they would say words that I did not know
they're like oh this is a duvet for the
for the duvet what the [ __ ] could you
say what the [ __ ] a duvet you have a
blanket over your blanket that's the
dumbest [ __ ] I've ever seen in my life
you don't have a [ __ ] washing machine
dumbass you know that's what I would
think your blanket has a blanket yeah I
was like what your blanket getting cold
bro yeah you know no I knew what was
going on in their life Oh put your shoes
in the four years I'm like four yeah
what the [ __ ] is this well saying right
now you mean like in front of the door
just say that you know what I mean and
like everything wouldn't make sense like
pictures would make sense the frames
match there's plants here because of
like it's organized yeah like for us it
was more like this is a couch you sit on
it we're gonna get this because I saw it
at a garage sale I'm gonna put it over
here and this I'm talking about like
poor Asian people right now if you go to
my house right now nothing makes sense
my house is brown in the front yellow in
the back brick on the side there's it
doesn't make sense like I don't
understand it you know what I mean I'll
tell my dad like yo this is ugly he goes
how's it ugly I'm like [ __ ] how is it
not okay so but didn't now tell me this
then Duke who is in Asian culture do
they are they not as infected by like
what the neighbors think and stuff like
that as white people are like what is
the exchange rate on that kind of I
don't think so like I feel like
culturally just like like ethnic people
we kind of just mind our own business
which is something that I I wish we
didn't have mean that's like back in the
day like you get to know your neighbors
so you keep your neighborhood safe so
that's kind of like that stuff of like
it's like integrated into our culture in
my personal opinion from what I've
experienced is that way no snitches
right you know no matter what like
you're actually nothing yeah like it's
like what you're not getting exactly you
don't I mean and I think it's just
because like you we just mind our own
business like the other day I was
kicking it with me and my couple of
homes from Sacramento and we're in South
Pasadena super nice
this dude hits this little kid hit a
softball went over the fence and rolled
right next to me I was like [ __ ] my
business right I stopped the whole thing
I should probably pick that up I didn't
think about it so it's not that you're
being rude you want to get involved it's
just that it's none of your business
yeah see I noticed that this is you know
like
in Shanghai I noticed a lot of the
Chinese people I know you're not Chinese
but the Chinese people were it always
seemed like they didn't like white
people seem to in or an America people
people seem to notice each other more
being around or like interact even to
send like regular moments on the train
or anything
Chinese people everybody very much in
their own what I perceived at the time
to be in their own world like didn't
care but you're saying so some of that
is more it's not my business so I don't
that's not my business it's not my
business but it's funny because once you
when it's not rude they're not being
rude I don't think so I think it's just
a cultural difference and I also to the
different other difference is that like
when Asian people they care a lot about
what their peers think about them though
hmm you know so like when I would do
stuff that wasn't that was I would I
call unsavory my parents be like well
what are they gonna say about us like
who
you know the people at the church you
know so how I dressed how I spoke how I
behave you know and they're just like oh
my god they're gonna say this about you
and they're gonna say that I'm a [ __ ]
cares man like [ __ ] the pastor do that
okay you gotta give up you know and
that's why I ran into a lot of trouble
actually got this for my mom because my
mom is like an I don't give a [ __ ] type
of person hmm you know what I'm saying
and so but my father was a pastor so
they always clashed in that kind of
sense oh wow my dad's like you know
carry yourself a little better you know
don't don't be walking or any you know
in Korean she would just curse left and
right she won't get my foot you know you
know what I mean our Koreans kind of
like black people kind of know you know
it's you know what it is to like and
that's a hell of a generalization but
I'm just asking like you know from like
how would you I see like you know the
culture parallels that I saw with the
Korean and black people is is that
number one family's important mm-hmm
number two we also beat our kids a lot
right so that's that's where I connected
a lot more so like my homie would get
beat with a switch I'll get beat with a
bamboo stick no I mean it was like and
that's not even a racial joke I would
legit get beat with a bamboo stick and
that was the worst thing ever I would
love to get hit by a belt a shoe a fist
a foot but the bamboo stick I [ __ ]
hate it and really what is it about it
you know why it's cuz that [ __ ]
was like so thin and slick like you
couldn't see it but you could hear it
so I'll use my mom would be mad she goes
come over out here and then I'm like
what happened then look at my shoulder
I'm like actually was ninja as [ __ ] I
hated that [ __ ] did every asian kid
knows it's that thin green bamboo stick
that you can get in a 24 pack oh and
that she doesn't break so when my
grandma would beat my ass but that [ __ ]
I'm really in a snap I was so happy and
then right behind the couch a dusty 24
pack I was like she beat me with the
same stick for damn near eight years and
she still had 23 left oh yeah that [ __ ]
had a Honda Civic a stick oh [ __ ] will
go a long way
wild man sorry to interrupt the episode
but I've also been doing a lot of
linoleum flooring you know I'm from the
flooring belt or a lot of people you
know they was walking around and
suddenly they wanted something different
under their feet and that's flooring and
you can learn about flooring or anything
you want as Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning platform and it has over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
social media marketing data science
mobile photography creative writing you
name it they got it you want it if you
got if you want to teach a fish to to um
to do something different I don't know
if they can help you do that but they
can help you do so much else join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners you get two months
of Skillshare for just 99 cents I can
well that's a dollar
that's right Skillshare is offering this
past weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents you got a dumb cousin
change his whole life up for a buck to
sign up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
th EO again go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo to start your two months now that
Skillshare comm slash Theo and good luck
with your learning time to sell you
something and that something is the MN
ml case that's the minimal case it's the
world
honest phone case and it really is I
mean this thing it is sleek is basically
like putting a little bit of a condom on
your phone you know it really is the
thinnest phone case in the world so if
your phone is trying to look sultry or
trying to attract men or other phones
then this could be that that customary
cover it is the absolute legally the
world's fit the thinnest phone case it's
just Oh point zero one inches thick
that's hardly any amount it shows more
the beauty of your phone now if your
phone hits the ground and stuff like
that I'm not saying that this bad boys
gonna take care of your phone you know
I'm saying it's not about that that's
that's that style it's not about that
you know that bumper-to-bumper traffic
but it is about actually having the
world's thinnest phone case in the world
and you can have that go to em in ml
case calm and use promo code Theo th e
oh that's em in ml case calm and use
promo code Theo for 15% off its 100%
money-back guarantee if you're unhappy
for whatever reason they will refund
your money and you don't even have to
send the case back so go on and get that
deal avoid that minimal case um jus I'm
just trying to think of any other things
that I thought like here's one thing
that I noticed some just because I don't
really get to talk to aging people that
much yeah so one thing that I feel
sometimes it's hard for me to know the
more I talk to you about it seems to
start to get a little bit easier for me
it's hard for me to know like what Asian
like if I'm around white people I come
around Nick and Nick's having like a
tough day our producer then I can maybe
I can kind of get a vibe from him you
know like oh man maybe you know Nick had
a long night or maybe Nick's you know
have some stuff going on at home or
something you know he's not maybe his
usual chipper self you know it's hard
for me to get a vibe of what Asian
people are like you know is that the
same the other way around I just don't
like that's the same by the way it is
for sure because I don't hang around a
lot of white people - right I said when
I'm with the college like I couldn't I
couldn't click with any white people you
know it was super hard for me like
the subject matters what would make them
laugh and I usually connect through
people through humor right I could see
that yeah so if I can't do that then
then we're kind of at a a loss like it's
not it's not gonna happen
you know what I'm right so for for me it
was I just didn't get it I still could
not wrap my I kind of got it now right
you know what I mean that there's a lot
of like I think especially in LA in the
LA area like a lot of white people like
hypothetical jokes I mean so they'll
create a scenario and that's the joke
that they usually say I say and this is
just me from an objective point of view
me writing notes right you know so
that's where a lot of humor comes in a
lot of like I guess it's kind of like
hood talk so I wouldn't just say like
Asian black and Mexican is just
everybody would like to clown on each
other yes you know we'll make fun of
each other cool you know what I mean and
that's the that's the kind of thing that
we have like Bart always clowns on yeah
it always makes fun of me but it makes
me like it more for some [ __ ] reason
man yeah and I you know what so as you
say that I think that that um and I was
talking about this with Joey Diaz uh you
know just recently but it's there's
something about that kind of culture
where you're out on the street making
fun of each other that brings people
closer together you know or just even
making fun of each other because if
you're making fun of each other in
somebody's there they know like and it's
not a main thing and if it is it does
get me and you can apologize yeah then
it's like that kind of [ __ ] brings
people together and whatever's a fun of
stuff was making fun of each other
hell yeah that was like how we bonded
with each other man sometimes you do
that should have funerals for crying out
loud
there was no holds bar and nowadays I
feel like so many kids nowadays are so
[ __ ] sensitive man because is it an
Asian community to or because it's
definitely in the way I don't it's
definitely in that Los Angeles it's
definitely in California do the rest of
America is not that [ __ ] sensitive
there maybe I'm in the wrong place then
cuz I miss that [ __ ] it's LA yeah you
just have to like be careful about what
you say and you know so a lot of people
there's like two things either you
really like me or you really hate me
right there's my problem is I don't give
a [ __ ] but like people would say like yo
man I don't think this guy likes you and
I'm like well good for him tell him to
go [ __ ] die for all I care you know
what I mean that's the sad part it's
like you think about me more than I
think about you oh I see
you know anything and so like I people
just they just want you to give a [ __ ]
so much now thank you
want you to give up not so bad and they
also want you to hate what they hate man
and if you don't hate what they hate
that means you're the enemy and so how
come I just can't have a different
opinion right it's okay like something
here's here's here's the wild thing
right so there are certain like YouTube
creators right they I watch their stuff
I don't like it you think of what you
know so what do you don't you like about
me and I say you I said I don't like
your content yes I like you perfectly
fine yeah
why do I have to like your stuff to like
you as a person I know and if I say I
don't like it
who the [ __ ] my [ __ ] me too yeah right
it's the other way around
[ __ ] what I think too yeah that's okay
if anything if you came out to me you
know what Damon I don't [ __ ] like you
a much man now I like you dude I like
you because at least I know where you
stand
yeah at least you're not doing this
whole you know yeah you know peace up
bro I really appreciate you [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you don't appreciate me just say
you hate me right and then I could
understand who you are yeah that's all
that it is and the people are so used to
doing this in LA where they go you know
what it's all about peace and love you
don't believe that [ __ ] that's true cuz
you're talking [ __ ] about me behind my
back right the difference between me and
you is I call you a [ __ ] loser
and I say behind your back - yeah so I'm
honest both ways around and if you hate
me I understand yes okay I understand
I'm not that lovable dude I get it now
are a lot of Asian people like you or is
this a writ so you are also uh Nanami
Lee yeah that's why I said remember like
I was like I can't keep comparing people
to my upbringing who as you know they
are who they are and I'm just I'm just a
little weird like I ya know you'd I mean
yeah like but you have to you almost
have to be I think to be able to grasp
as many different like kind of levels of
humor and stuff as you you know do you
able to relate to different people humor
wise yeah cuz that's the first thing I
was like oh this guy's super funny to me
like he must is he as funny to Asian
people is he is funny to other
ethnicities like I wonder if that
transcends does it matter I wonder I
don't think it matters like a you know a
friend of Mines trying to do stand-up
right now and then you know I used to
stand up and all I wanted to be was a
stand-up comedian growing up yeah and
then I found out actually started liking
riding better more than doing stand-up
you know so he was asking me he goes
well how do I do stand-up and not offend
people is like what if you're thinking
about if any people you should do
stand-up
mmmn have an opinion whether whether
whether you like it or not whether they
like it or not you still had to start
from point A to point B you can't stay a
joke and be like oh but you know
no you got to go all the way through
yeah you know and I think people are so
scared to do that so you know in my
personal opinion like when I see a lot
of stand-up now like I'm like you I love
stand-up so I love watching everybody
you know the everybody that can make me
laugh I want to watch it and it's just
kind of like I see this thing where
people backpedal on stand-up now
mm-hmm they have to say something and
preface it with something so people
don't get offended it's like well you
know you just ruin the joke just say
your joke bro right you know and if
people get offended that's okay that's
why I love Patrice O'Neal so much yeah
you know he said something great he was
like half the room should be laughing
and the other half should be horrified
yeah you know and i genuinely believe
that's true that's why I wash yourself
that was [ __ ] hilarious yeah you have
something to say you know so you know
that kind of arts dying out a little bit
and everybody wants to do stand-up
because everybody's so used to telling
somebody oh you can do it can you really
don't
can you really though yeah but do you
think it's uh do you think it's gonna
start to swing the other way some of
this panel I think it has to oh yeah
there's no way that like people gonna
continue to listen a [ __ ] boring lame
[ __ ] that you know that advertisers
say is good yeah you know that's why you
have people like you that's like Jim
Jeffries is still bill burr there's all
these people it will birds the one day I
[ __ ] love Bill burr man like when I
when I started doing stand-up again
somebody mentions like you kind of
robbed me of like bilborough's like I
don't know who Bill burr was because I
only listen to black stand-up comedians
yeah at the time yeah it was only like
the station first
yeah like Eddie Merc there was no like
Korean like stand-up for me that I could
look up to besides Bonnie Lee at the
time yeah yeah I know how much [ __ ]
cloud is he must have it he's the only
one he doesn't even know it either no I
keep telling the dude last like bro you
were my hero and he goes I don't
understand I'm not that dope and I'm
like dude you had the lowest self-esteem
for somebody who has influenced so many
Asian people he has no muscles in his
body you know that you know it's all
[ __ ] gristle it's amazing what even
his skeleton together
Rohit definitely like if they cut him
open and a buffet it would be a desert
you know what is this oh you can hug him
and completely reshape him do not
squeeze him on the sides you other day
and he was like for the rest of the day
he's like four inches taller
he's so malleable that dudes like he
cracked me up man is the only one yeah
he says some wild [ __ ] dude
that stuff - that's true and I've always
like loved his stand-up you know it's
it's it's not like the stand-up that I
normally like which is a little bit more
precise yeah I mean because he's a
little bit out there he's a little bit
more showy yes but like it's so genuine
hi Jen that's why that's why I love his
podcast so much you know I mean he's
authentic yeah and I probably liked his
podcast more than I like to stand up
which I didn't think was possible yeah
just because like for him it's not even
making jokes he's just a weird dude yeah
he's just crazy he's wearing all that
[ __ ] like he's trying to flex his nuts I
was over there two days ago there we are
right there and he's trying to flex his
[ __ ] nuts and they added those shorts
in I didn't wear those shorts right
Bobbi shorts are real feels are ya Bobby
sure - real they also edit in a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] in his pants yeah full
watermelon in there oh yeah that's
actually that is big that's his ball
sack because I saw that [ __ ] in real
life as dick is very sad-looking his his
ball sacks are huge so we were very dark
- oh my god man you would think there
was something wrong with like his balls
are holding their breath yeah I guess we
were we did a live podcast and I was a
guest and who's got but Nick and I
started grinding up on a dude yeah and
from the back side I could see his ball
sack like like they were trying to run
away from him oh definitely I mean they
were so long long balls a very long very
Quayle ish almost it's almost looks like
he's giving birth to like a little baby
duck you know it's like that it's more
of an amniotic sac and his ball his ball
sack legit looks like that last drop on
a faucet that wants to fall down yeah
you know it's just kind of dangling me
and then you just SPECT it just fall out
I was kind of surprised I was like I've
never seen so much ball sack from behind
something yeah before and he puts a pine
Glee he said he puts a pine scent on his
nut sometimes which i think is
fascinating for an Asian person even use
pine it's just such a simple old-school
kind of you know I found that this me
and anyone used pine you know one of
those like interesting Korean dudes man
like he kind of made me feel when I was
a kid that I wasn't the odd person out
anymore oh that's interesting like
there's other Korean people out there
that's kind of like me that can be silly
yeah that could be silly that's not so
serious all the [ __ ] time
now you but no so tell me this so you
were a youth minister yeah tell me about
some of that man
that's fascinating so in your culture is
there a lot of is Christianity the main
were you guys Christian and if so kind
of what branch are you guys in
Presbyterian at first though yeah might
well my father a lot of church bells yep
so my dad he opened up his own trust
because he's a pastor so he opened up
his own church after the words where it
was nondenomination and so from that you
know long story short I didn't know what
the [ __ ] I wanted to do I just know I
like talking to people I like making
people feel happy and good about
themselves right
I thought yo maybe like ministry is my
calling and so you know I I tried it out
for a couple of years and I wanted to do
it and I worked at my dad's church lo
and behold if I know it's not my calling
like being a pastor is one of the most
difficult jobs on earth because because
it really was that anything anything bad
that happens is your fault it doesn't
[ __ ] matter either you didn't pray
enough and you know people are looking
for that outlet and it's understandable
like churches of what I call it like a
hospital for broken people you know it's
not for people who are perfect you're
looking for somebody to help you that's
why you come to church so when you're
the the leader of this group and you
don't have these answers and when you
tell them things are gonna be okay and
you should trust in God and it doesn't
happen sometimes people get mad at you
hmm and I wasn't very good with that I
grew up as a very angry person so some
of these kids like I'm talking about
she'd be leading them like I was so
[ __ ] petty there's this kid he said he
was good at basketball and I was
substantially better than him you know
at the time you know and as a pastor you
should be lifting this kid up yeah you
go for a lip and I was swatted yes you
know what had been like in the name of
the Lord
back in your [ __ ] face now go home
and pray [ __ ] wow I was that guy I'm
like yo maybe cuz he just wants to show
off and have fun I just gotta humble him
a little yeah he was like five foot
three
oh and he's like trying to do all these
fancy moves and I would just you know
trip him a little bit yeah throw some
dust it's a little bit of Lord in him
yeah you know you're the God exactly and
so like I you know I remember the last
day I realized I couldn't do this and it
was because it's the same [ __ ] kid he
was like this [ __ ] rich kid Oh God
right then that he had the world he he
got in trouble and his parents are
asking me to help him out because he had
an addiction to codeine so hoxsey
oxycontin or whatever right yeah and
scissor uh-huh
so he's like mesh is expensive as [ __ ]
hmm so
he would steal like his relative [ __ ]
and sell it so he can get more pills and
he got into so much lately legal trouble
his parents were just asked out on money
and his parents are pretty well-off and
this guy kid would kept on talking about
during Bible said how cool he is and I
got so [ __ ] mad at him I literally
punched this desk in half mm-hmm
in front of the hole which is very Asian
thing to do if you look at a lot of old
Asian videos they're constantly breaking
chopping stuff a half and I said that it
because like what happens is like church
and Culture mix too because I'm still
it's still a Korean Church there's still
Korean culture but there's still Jesus
there right but I was too Korean oh man
like it was like this flimsy table but I
still punched it and have my staff that
I was like this is not for me I hate
these kids
I [ __ ] hate them if they go to hell
I'm like well deserved that's what I was
thinking in the back of my head Wow and
they're praying I'm like what are you
praying for you're not going to get my
head I'm like oh [ __ ] I need Jesus yeah
I can't be preaching I need to go to
church you need to be in this class
exactly and I'm gonna teach these kids
about God what I'm praying on their
downfall
you're lucky winking at the devil yeah
now we do Carrera is the Korean church
and why people church kind of the same
oh no it's way different media like
culture weighs heavy in Asian American
churches just like almost culture first
Christ next hmm you know what I mean
like we're talking about like you could
go to like a Korean or Japanese Church
and you'll go there and they it's not
even your person they could beat your
ass Joe Wow just because you're Korean I
like that second aunt asked me yeah dude
I would get like a swoop it's all the
[ __ ] time who the [ __ ] was that
yeah those looked his business card like
people would beat your ass in church and
they would tell your parents that I beat
him up because he did this and then my
parents would apologize to them for
having them slap me around oh wow you
know honor and then I would go home and
then again my ass beat again it's like
you would think I'd be a lot better at
fighting out of it but I'm not so Korean
people so it's more is there more of a
groupthink like as it grew like it's
okay if you help me raise my kids a
little bit or it's okay if you keep them
in line it's like is there more respect
do you feel like from young people to
adult yeah it's it oh definitely man
there's a chain of command to the max
especially in Asian culture like there's
like even certain instances that you
could read about there was a Japanese
airline a few years back that had a
terrible terrible incident that happened
where the for the pilot
planning to commit suicide and kill
everybody on the plane which he did he
did do it and so what they found out
through communication I don't know how
they found this out but I think it said
even in a book but the second the
copilot knew that he was gonna commit
suicide right but in Asian cultures even
specifically a Japanese culture - he
don't want to speak out of turn so he
didn't say anything out of respect and
they [ __ ] crashed and everybody died
because oh I can't say nothing you know
which is so [ __ ] wild and they say
something next life
yeah and that's that happened at a
Korean airline - or something similar to
it which you could probably look it up
there yeah there it is right there like
1 2 3 crash Wow and first of all calling
it flight 1 2 3 crash I was flight 123
how does like that's the war I thought
there was the airline name 1 2 3 crash 1
2 3 crack yeah yeah it's so like it's
it's kind of wild like you could look up
and and so they I think like to a lot of
Honor a lot of like you know when the
talking not to talk you think about
Japanese culture and like Howdy key or
seppuku anybody who can kill themselves
out of Honor that's the wildest thing to
me yeah me too like I've shamed myself
let me kill my - [ __ ] that dude like I
shaved myself oh well yeah you know and
I just move on yeah so you're pretty
westernized westernized is [ __ ] right I
love America dude my people even asked
me like yo Korea and America go to war
who used to America
really yeah we got we got the artillery
son it's so crazy there's a lot of
people in America who their first thing
is to not that's sometimes what gets me
sometimes or there's something that X me
is it's like is it coming to America and
then not even wanting to be for America
yeah I'm for America man like this is my
country I mean I'm from here some for
America but I feel like if I went and
lived in another country I wouldn't just
stand over there in that country in
before America the whole time you know
it's like if I'm living here and I'm
part of what's going on here then you
know like I have some friends who are
they'll vote in different elections of
like well I'm gonna do what's best for
you know whatever country my
grandparents are from is something I'm
like what the [ __ ] you talkin about like
you live here and it's their choice but
to me that just makes you feel
uncomfortable for ya like for me like I
love Korea South Korea I mean that's a
part of my heart
I love that place but if you're asking
me who I am like I'm an American
like I've benefited from this country so
much you know I mean there's a reason
why I pay taxes here there's a reason
why I like this country is because I
wouldn't be Who I am if it wasn't for
this country right not to say that I'm
I can never cut out my South Korean
heritage and culture but I didn't grow
up there yeah I don't know the culture I
don't know they they didn't they didn't
put anything into my pull of life that
helped me be Who I am my parents did and
that's why I know how to speak uh you
know read and write in Korean but when
it comes down to it I'm American right
yeah I mean I got raised that American
flag yeah that's what it is that's cool
you know you know it's cool to hear I
mean it's just cool to see like you know
just cool coming from a place where we'd
all be mostly I was black and white and
it's neat to see that like you know you
don't see yeah it's neat to see that
people like America that aren't just
white now there's this thing now it's
like if you like the American flag it's
like you're racist white person I feel
like there's this crazy vibe going on
which is not true and it's not fair I
had a conversation just yesterday about
that man so a friend of ours was talking
about how he's out he's out in Vegas
right now right and he says like is
don't you find it so weird when you see
a dude in a huge pickup truck and he's
waving an American flag and you feel
like he's racist yeah I think why is it
I was it oh [ __ ] why does that I think
it's the American it's not a Confederate
flag right the American flag and you
feel something negative towards that and
it's weird because that's our country
it's our flag yeah but not now there's
like a negative stigma towards I don't
know why I think it's advertising has
done that like you know they just push
that in the last couple years where it's
like oh this is it's on American if you
like the American flag I think a lot of
that happened with the to me it seems
like a lot of that happened with the
election with Trump and um in Clinton
was that Trump kind of in bra you know
he used the American flag a lot and
Hillary used this other was like an H
flag with like an arrow in it kind of
look like a feta a little bit of that
FedEx kind of arrow but like they took
on a different type of emblem and so I
think that that whereas the parties you
know if you're a Republican or a
Democrat it used to be like one of them
had like an elephant and one um had a
donkey yeah
she had like the I'm with her and there
was like just an h1 that even just had
like an H and so whereas Trump stuff was
all like someone was Trump but then also
the American flag seemed to go with
attached to him yeah I kind of got
attached and so then I think that that's
what it was but the scary thing to me
was growing up you had all these car
commercials right and truck commercials
and they had the American flag in them
and they had a truck right and like buy
this this is American you know this is
American drive a truck this is a mayor
and so a lot of people bought into that
you know that's where they got their
some of their idea of America a lot of
it comes from advertising so it's like
well all these people were doing their
this the children a lot of people
driving these big trucks of the flags
most of them are just the children or of
people who watch those commercials
growing up or they themselves saw those
you know it's just the advertising and
now suddenly the advertising a lot of
the advertising is like oh that's not
American if you you know it's like an
American but it's like what you're the
same advertise you're like twenty years
ago it was okay to be like I don't know
something buddy it is weird it's like
why if I have an American flag now do I
feel that that's racist I don't ever
want to feel that yeah like it's there's
like a negative like cloud around it too
I mean you know more about I don't know
[ __ ] about politics dude absolutely
[ __ ] nothing yeah and when people
talk about politics I'm just like oh
[ __ ] this is not my conversation you
know cuz people would ask it's so funny
like people on social media they look at
like these new media people like
youtubers and like you should talk about
politics I'm like why I don't know [ __ ]
alright yeah I just know who the
president is and I just pay my taxes
like a good American yeah that's all I
[ __ ] and they're like whoa how come
you don't know more about policy should
speak more about I'm not gonna speak
[ __ ] about stuff I don't know know about
you know yeah I'll make jokes about it
but even then to make jokes about
politics you have to know what's going
on right and I don't and people always
bring up like these like like Paulo
politicians names and stuff and they're
like what do you think I'm like let me
give a [ __ ] yeah it's all turning into
the WWE anyway everything is quick bro
quickly everything's turning in it's all
gonna be wrestling we're all gonna be
shootin wrestling you see is becoming
the WWE for cryin I'm the W and and
they're talking about the rock running
for office next term
I mean it's all beak it's all merging
into exactly what it's supposed to we're
in this me time everybody has an
Instagram everybody has a can put
commercials out for themself it's it all
makes sense that that's what it is like
what I feel like what happened with this
last election is that they were they
were specifically campaigning in my
personal opinion to get the youth to
come in and vote mm-hmm and the only way
you can get these [ __ ] young kids to
vote is if you create drama right and I
think it kind of backfired you know what
I mean like yeah you gosh you got the
youth to vote but it wasn't even you
know but then like look what happened
right we have this like reality TV star
as a president right now you now like
the rock being the president like mind
you I [ __ ] love the rock I love the
rock too I'm gonna [ __ ] how bad his
movies are I'm watching every single one
of that's an Asian thing then yeah
that's who's watching him I'll tell you
doctor tell you right now do the rundown
what's it called walking tall where he
played the same character with just two
different movie names you know it was
the same [ __ ] movie he just walks and
pulls up an eyebrow and kick somebody's
ass yeah and I don't know why but I but
now that he's a president he says he's
gonna be the president people don't go
absolutely not big right why not why not
why not the rockin right and then I hope
that who's gonna run against him
Baltimore like that's the thing though
anything can happen and the crazy thing
about son was about Hollywood is
Hollywood create like dude nobody like
people had heard of Donald Trump right
you always heard of like Trump you dress
like a rich person but if it wasn't for
that show
then someone in Hollywood made a billion
dollars on for Apprentice it wasn't for
that show he never would have had enough
popularity to be yeah known that much
you know it's and also to all these
people all these politicians were
friends with him and suddenly he's the
worst person in the world like what why
wasn't either worst person like it's
just we're all [ __ ] up yeah and it's
just like yeah we don't want the most
fucked-up guy being president and I
think we'll get to a place where we
learn about that you know but I just
hate sometimes like how acting that
we're better than we're not better than
where we are yeah we're where we are
because of who we are yeah you know like
in a weird way trumps on his third wife
she bought he bought her from another
country or whatever
that's half the [ __ ] dudes I know
dude you know why I feel so [ __ ] bad
because like as somebody who as a
comedian I really enjoy the fact that
Trump is so funny oh he's a pro he's
taller his son Donald Jr is hilarious
man like forever in my life I will
remember Trump going up to a whole crowd
of people say I wish my wife was here
and she's right next day she flew in the
[ __ ] plane with I'm a [ __ ] maniac
you know what I mean if only I were here
and she's sitting there like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like what in the world would you
have ever saw that in the history of you
know to me and I'm just sitting there
like this is I mean it's terrible for a
country but like this is mad
entertaining but I think a lot of people
for some reason it's also like let's
let's put somebody in office who at
least you can look at Trump you're like
[ __ ] he's cheat on his taxes you know he
you know he knows why I have trouble
communicating obviously he has a son
that they say may have autism you know
[ __ ] I can kind of [ __ ] relate to
that guy you know that's like half I
mean set you know is it's a doors it
just who we are you know like I could
relate to Barack Obama in a way that I
was inspired that you know I thought it
was super inspirational and I have he
was like a more of a figure that you
would look like it was his it was more
of an inspiration type of thing you know
like young black men or young diverse it
you know somebody that's different you
can you can have any dream you want you
know like after that a lot of complaints
like some black people saying they can't
do this or people of you were mixed or
different or even just poor anybody like
anybody could do [ __ ] anything you
know what it is like people are just
always gonna be discontent about
something ya know but like you know the
issue with like Trump that people have
is like you want you want your president
to be presidential right that's the
thing and then everybody thought that oh
we want somebody just like me to be up
there no you [ __ ] don't you are trash
yeah you do not want trash to run this
company
yeah or this country or anything you
know any but I think people kind of like
it because it's [ __ ] here's the thing
it's entertaining I think he keeps the
news channels in business nobody wants
[ __ ] more yeah
is this it yes at that Florida rally
yesterday he addressed the
acting presidential okay let's hear that
[Applause]
looks like he already died so funny
ladies and gentlemen of the state of
Florida thank you very much for being
you are tremendously tremendous he loves
that and I will leave now because I am
boring you to death oh my god this guy's
while he's trolling the whole [ __ ]
thing broke you know he's gonna win
again man you know what he has man he
got this he you know why he released he
got that white people hate face man it's
that he oh he does have that like I'm
better than you white people face he
does that's why Allah but they all have
it him and Hillary of the st. I thought
they had the same face oh she got that
same face too man like that's why people
said it's a lesser of two evils yeah you
know I technically don't really know
what that means like in terms of like
politics why you're like can't we do
better than this yeah I just don't like
I don't know why I think we will I'd
like to see him and Bernie in a steel
cage match against Shawn Michaels and
Marty Jannetty are both has got so alive
yes they are I feel like Bernie farted
his kneecaps would explode we have a
chance that's all yeah he's he is he is
but as a tag-team duo them to Bernie and
Trump on a tag team
maybe dude Trump no I mean in actual
wrestling match like I'm just saying
it's all headed towards interview a you
know I'm saying like so quickly yo
wasn't Trump in a WWF or WBE episode yes
definitely she was right
yes it's people want [ __ ] in are we
not are you not entertained people at
the very least they want to be
entertained now you have to [ __ ] you
better [ __ ] Entertainment oh we want
the reality well here's one thing I
didn't like that I don't like is I don't
like the hatred of Melania like I don't
get that she's an immigrant right sure
she may be a gold digger every [ __ ] 95%
of the women in [ __ ] Los Angeles or
gold diggers you know I think I wonder
what maybe they hate her because she's
an immigrant and he's like supposed to
be the the hate the hate he hates
immigrants but she's an immigrant so
it's just so weird why well the a does
he hate immigrants if he has a [ __ ]
Aviva so I don't know maybe only likes
pretty you know who knows he's can't
hate her he doesn't know she exists for
crying he'll probably doesn't [ __ ] so
funny when I see her at everything and
she just looks so pissed off she's so
angry all the time I think she wondered
if you probably had a moral
axing life and now she's thrust into but
do you think for she's the first lady of
[ __ ] America she grew up in where
where does she worry from like if you
want to talk about the it's just weird
it's like there's such a crazy dichotomy
going on if you want to talk about the
American dream for a woman to move to a
country and you could be whatever you
want to be the first lady she's if she
is an example of it now is it the most
Cavalier way to get there I don't know I
would have never thought that I'd be
able to see the titties of the first
lady - no because you could see her
titties right now if you wanted to use
go look at Melania Trump naked and it's
like damn dude look at those Tatas I
think it's just that yeah and I think
it's all a way to get to somewhere
better man I would love to see what
Asian ethnicity would be the best to be
our first president of America [ __ ] I
don't know that's hard to say man Korean
people are always angry Japanese people
are angry and then sometimes - nice
Vietnamese people are wow this [ __ ]
Cambodian scare me yeah what's up with
the Modi's boy what do they call him
Bodie then shambo's Cambodians man like
just just the Cambodian like yeah
whatever you went through just like the
Khmer like what all that other stuff man
like if you talk about gang violence man
I'm talking about long beach anywhere
Stockton Modesto Cambodian people know
what's up you guys are [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] with Cambodian really no I'm
talking about you could even look this
[ __ ] up like this is some real [ __ ] like
people gangs understood at that time
like this is when I was super young you
don't [ __ ] with [ __ ] Southeast Asian
refugees cuz you will come up too many
but I'll [ __ ] it I'll [ __ ] you up that's
cool I'm gonna chop your [ __ ] head
off and leave it on a railroad track Wow
and that [ __ ] would legit happen I think
that happened in Stockton or something
too and they'll make soup out of
somebody they don't go they don't let
any railway they don't give a [ __ ] cuz
they came from a war-torn country you
know so what are you saying that's any
more scary to me I grew up with a K in
my hand right now as a kid right now
you're talking about you gonna [ __ ]
ride out on me it's like I will chop
your feet off and leave it as a necklace
yeah for fun yeah and I'll count only
with your toes and not my finger are
using yet as if my calculator [ __ ]
and this yes yeah I'll do mapping or
tell them you see we got uh
wow that's crazy Cambodian so yeah give
me some give me some more knowledge like
if I'm just a regular white person and I
meet an Asian person how can I know or a
regular black person or anybody who
doesn't know a lot of Asian people how
can i is there a way to know that
somebody is Korean I don't know we just
gotta look creepy people look like
Korean people okay are there any hints
or any way cream people are a lot more I
mean they're a lot more angrier we have
a short [ __ ] temper oh really it's
just part of our culture dude we're
short a dynamite huh short temper does
hell man like I don't know I you know I
think it's cuz our history is so dark
and sad that a lot of people have it
they call it hot which is I think it
means like it means like anger or even
like revenge hmm like Korean if you look
up Korean films our [ __ ] revenge
films are the [ __ ] best yeah my
favorite film on earth is this film
called I saw the devil I saw the devil
let's put a link to that in the show
today yeah yeah it's and it's the
ultimate revenge film well and it's so
[ __ ] satisfying man like this is so I
mean you just I love that [ __ ] I love
revenge films I got I don't [ __ ] know
why man but it when somebody gets their
just desserts it's like that's how [ __ ]
yes yeah that's wow so you
so do Korea it so that they like things
being fair is that what it is when you
say just heard they like okay this guy
got wrong then now let's see how he does
it right everything is so dramatic I
think in Korean culture I think that's
like the beauty of our culture to know
it's very dramatic I like that you look
at Korean dramas say they love drama I
think so man they always like something
that's popping off or going on and even
like Korean lightly kpop music look how
look how strong of a wave that is I mean
my people we have a strong influence
like Chinese people even in America dude
if you go to these kpop concerts in
America all white people all white
people that want to look Korean when
Korean people want to look white Oh bro
the craziest thing in China that I did
see was a lot of surgery to look white
to the point where sometimes it was very
it made me feel sad you don't even look
human anymore man it made me feel sad
people had gotten their eyes kind of
rounded like but oddly rounded almost
and then their skin some of their skin
bleached and the girls blah you know
straightening their hair to an insane
length and blondie
it like Korea is like one of the top and
like like prosthetic surgeries or
whatever oh really this cheaper there
too so a lot of people go out like these
k-pop stars if you look at their
pictures of what they used to look like
before they got into the industry
completely different dude all that
plastic surgery and they all look
exactly the same it's almost like they
look anime they went to the same [ __ ]
doctor they didn't think about switching
it up you know so they all cut
themselves the same [ __ ] way
mm-hm and even like for somebody like my
girlfriend right she grew up super
Korean and she goes all those people
look so good in my mind like they look
like [ __ ] freaks right they don't
look human
what are you yeah with the bright pink
lipstick and the pale ass skin you look
like a [ __ ] ghost don't talk to me
yeah it's very wild and and their
celebrities have a very it's the same
look it's like it's almost like an it's
not an I know to what it's I don't know
what it is but it's a very same look
it's almost like looking like the idea
of a celebrity more than just being
yourself that's the one thing that you
know even though people talk about in
America how they want you to be skinny
in a certain way but compared to other
countries not so much man like that we
do have like diverse looks here like
especially even even in modeling they
want to find that different look the
person with the freckles the person with
the red hair the blue I'm not in Korea
no it's it's more like you want let's
say an American yeah let's look you
should look like this you should have
this the the fair-skinned the the pink
you know the rounded eyes the small
jawline a compliment in Korea is this
like you have a fair you have a small
face wow that's a compliment I'm gonna
say you already waited Kotoko been
talking love yeah they would say [ __ ]
like that mean joke oh man means like
small took a mini yes I so I'm like am i
you know my mom would say that - oh why
is your face so small my [ __ ] is it a
compliment dude says that you don't mean
the Pacers are so small like a little
peanut you know like it seemed fun be an
agent is it fun for you to be agent it
seemed like fun because you have such
like a kind of a wider view of things a
little bit you know in there yeah love
culture dude like that's why like
culture I think culture is American you
know what I mean people got it twisted
sometimes they're like oh I have to be
more American no you being who you are
where you're from is American that's it
I agree yeah people are always and one
thing I don't like is oh it's like okay
we need to change America to be like
these places so those people can feel
comfortable here
[ __ ] no those will just let it be how it
is that's what America is if it's a
melting pot let it be a [ __ ] melting
pot don't say we have ok let's we have
to make sure every Chinese person feels
comfortable in class and we need to make
one of the whole walls about China like
just [ __ ] let it be a shitty wall
like it was when we're all in school and
that and let that person be who they are
you know we don't have to put it on a
wall and then nobody can talk about
anything and then we say we did it like
we're checking a box yeah like I like
celebrating other cultures you know
that's just what it is just let it be
yeah and don't don't [ __ ] on somebody
for being who they are and then that
that's like the beauty of America you
know I mean we this country is supposed
to be built on immigrants yeah you know
people coming here be able to express
their religion their thoughts you know
who they are and their cultures and once
you kind of take that away you say well
let's stop raising this racism by taking
everything away then you're not American
anymore right this is not America
anymore right then it's not then it's
something else then it's North Korea
yeah it really is man and I hate that I
hate that thought too cuz back in the
day - they would stop like you could ask
any like immigrant like Asian immigrants
that came here like mmm 30 40 years ago
and their parents there's like second
generation Asian kids that don't know
how to speak their language because
their parents said you need to be more
American don't know wow because they're
afraid the kids were gonna get bullied
they were gonna get Punk'd they were
gonna get made fun of which they did you
know they got made fun of for having an
accent or eating weird [ __ ] food yeah
you know your lunch box have had like
squid and [ __ ] oh yeah you know and when
I was a kid I remember this my mom made
like kimchi fried rice and I put it in
this little little bento box thing and I
took it and I my dad was like don't take
that he goes why cuz this smells funny
and kids are gonna make fun of you yeah
he was right and he was right I didn't
understand it right you know cuz even as
a little kid I might get [ __ ] but for a
kid I should've gave more [ __ ] right I
mean I should care more about what
people have thought yeah at that time
for me but like um take this anyways it
tastes good and I took it and I got made
fun of for it but it was damn delicious
yeah yeah you know I give a [ __ ] I was
like stuffing and they're like yeah that
smells [ __ ] your what you know I will be
real no dude whenever the white kids
brought this [ __ ] Wonder Bread uh-huh
with ham and American cheese cuz I
wouldn't get it yes I'm like [ __ ] I'll
trade you I'll trade you my [ __ ] and
squid rice
trade that [ __ ] yes some guys ooh look
at your suck in the oceans dick over
here this [ __ ] sack of snakes I
[ __ ] loved why people sandwiches man
till this day one of my favorite I could
eat a sandwich every day for the rest of
my life
wow you love sandwiches I love
sandwiches man I don't there's something
American and delicious about a sandwich
yeah I [ __ ] love that [ __ ] dude my
mom would get so angry she does like
sandwiches so much that's like you just
don't make it for me yeah yeah little
[ __ ] Jimmy got the [ __ ] American
Chef [ __ ] Mayo on there and somehow
that ham would be a perfect square maybe
when I'm Wonder Bread and I love that
[ __ ] mayonnaise I love mayonnaise do
Asian people what's a condiment that
Asian people love that we don't know
well no I mean each people love
mayonnaise and so our but Japanese
people they're like are they like too
cool for school or like what are they
like they're just quieter you know I
never grew up around too much Japanese
people but like for me like Japanese
people and Korean people are very
similar they are yeah
but I think like this is this is my
observation ya know and then yeah we're
not yeah this is just my view like I'm
just curious traveling all over like
Korean people are so funny because like
every Korean knows that Korean people
love talking [ __ ] [ __ ] love that they
think they're better than they think
they're better than everybody
Korean people hate Korean people that's
what we got in North and South Korea Wow
I can't even get along with each other
and you figure that out you know what
I'm saying yeah like I think like the
Korean War started with somebody got in
a fight with the reflection like that's
nice [ __ ] started out you know to be and
so the Korean people are so funny to me
because like Japanese people are some of
the nicest human beings I've met and
mind you they had like the negative
caveats they work really they they work
their people to death you know there's
like this weird like social dynamic
that's kind of odd there but like Korean
people think they're fancy like Japanese
people but they think they're better
than Chinese people in like Korean but
we have Samsung but we'll still spit on
the floor and smoke and squat on the
United mean right so we're like a mix
between everybody they want to be
everything kind of yes that's how I see
my my people it's like you think you're
[ __ ] fancy but you're actually not
and you judge people like everybody else
is gray which is like the Korean soul
which funny is like a negative thing but
I kind of like it as judgment yeah
the revenge the [ __ ] their like being
like they like - what is it like I would
hear a lot of like old Korean people
like talk about other Asian Asian
cultures and she would crack me up
because you know it's a good nummies
people that's a 3830 Asian did you
notice that Japanese are people Chinese
are people the Korean people the worst
what is going on you're like that's
everybody that's like that's what my dad
would say he goes never do business with
the Chinese people the world cream
people never accordion people I'm like
wait who should you do business with
don't do business with anybody it's like
okay what is the worst is lesson going
you know II mean my dad would say [ __ ]
like white people are no Mary's like
white they they love a divorce like it's
hot yes divorce it is like it's a
hostile area love with divorce I don't
think they love divorce dad like you
know like that's like the American Way
like white people say together no there
goes and marry and then go other way
that's the marriage of white people do
people stay married more in Korean
culture yeah really who even if they're
unhappy they stay together not so much
anymore but they think more about the
family unit so it's like if we separate
and that's also because they don't want
to be here [ __ ] from other families
think about what other people say I'm
not saying it's like that now right
that's what I grew up with with a lot of
families they stayed together for the
kids and also because they didn't want
to be shamed but is their sin and so in
some ways people will be like oh that's
[ __ ] up get out there and do your
thing and you know go on and be happy
but in other ways was there something is
there something that's kind of neat
about that as well
I like the fact that they care about the
family unit so much right they would
sacrifice themselves for their children
yeah and you know in that kind of sense
they they would think that it's better
but sometimes it's better just to be
away from somebody that hates you right
you know and they but at the same time
ajan the joy and a Korean household when
you and your husband hate each other and
just slowly [ __ ] getting revenge I
used to think my parents hate it but
they love each other very much it's hard
to tell sometimes when Korean parents
hate each other yeah cause it's always
mad anyways you don't mean like hi so
I'm like yes flirting like what's going
on here are you guys about to [ __ ] but
with knives yeah
what's going on dude like I saw my mom
once throw a rice cooker at my dad's
head and he just ducked and it shattered
everywhere and and I would share these
stories were like that's foreplay yeah I
guess they were [ __ ] there's
something later on that night but I
would see violence in my house man yeah
and it was just no I would share these
stories too like white kids at college
and they would just be mortified yeah
you know I was like yeah I remember my
mom like she would like go into the room
and my dad would be so mad she locked
door he would kick that door down I'll
hear them screaming whoa what the hell
I'm like that's just a normal Sunday
well we had dinner right after this
Korean hide-and-go-seek real hell yeah
dude do you know how I used to get beat
the most creative [ __ ] way dude my
dad used to have me hold this chair
above my head and this is a Korean thing
they would have you hold [ __ ] up above
your head Michael you know so at you
could only hold it for so long before it
starts to drop down right but if it
would drop they would [ __ ] whack you
with the stick and so eventually what
would happen is my arms would get so
tired the chair would smack my head and
my dad would hit me in the ass so just
the whole time like if a white person
was watching that in the in through a
window they would think it we were
preparing for a [ __ ] show and I
shared this [ __ ] with my teacher her
name was Miss Escobar cuz well I got
caught plagiarizing oh yeah and I got my
ass beat now it's telling like this is
what you did to me and she just started
laughing her ass off she don't care
she's Mexican
she's like I'm gonna use that yeah she
still mentions until this day I love
that lady Beth that's funny dude we had
a couple of calls that came in Nick yeah
get to a couple of them hi this is Lilly
I wanted to ask a question for David
when you're assuming the moody [ __ ] what
message that you want like the audience
to take away from it and then what was
the unexpected message that people took
out of it that you guys did not intend
for it to be deep seems kind of like a
leading question where does she already
know this answer so you have a film
called [ __ ] can you tell us about that
yeah so [ __ ] is a film that's kind of
based around the LA riots okay and it's
not about the LA riots you know if you
if you want to know what the LA riots
are about you go watch a [ __ ]
documentary this is not about that this
is about
yeah can I cut you know just to answer
her question like what we wanted people
to understand was the community and
family so [ __ ] is represented a lot
about I mean justin chon wrote it and I
helped write certain parts about it too
mmm
and then I also helped produce an
enacting it and I just what we wanted
people to take away from this was that
during those times and even till this
day it's those people were affected so
differently and it wasn't about hating
each other it was two communities that
didn't understand each other hmm and so
how I put this as is this so you have
this black community I did they've been
here for [ __ ] years yeah can't bring
a picture of it Nick please and they
can't get a bank loan to open up a
business that's like systemic racism
that happens to them right and then you
had these Asian people that come to this
country bank loan like that yeah they
start opening up businesses in their
neighborhood and all they see is like yo
these people are profiting off of us you
know and we're gonna over here
struggling and this is something that's
very true to me because my parents owned
a black beauty supply store right what
they don't know is I kill did you know
that we're also struggling to just cuz
we have a business doesn't mean we're
rich right actually poor we're on
welfare you don't know that and we're to
to communities that are struggling but
when you're starving and you're worried
about your own all you can see is your
own problems you know so you're not
worried about what your neighbor is
going through you're trying to just put
food on your table for your family right
so when you're worried about your own
issues you don't care to have empathy
towards somebody else mmm in my personal
opinion that that's what was happening
with like the Asian and black community
Wow
so and that's kind of like a lot of what
[ __ ] really is about this is about
people and what you find out is that you
guys are actually very similar you guys
are going through the same struggles and
you guys all have the same goals right
and there's even this thought about you
know Asian people don't like black
people well that's not true at all it's
Asian people came into this country and
they had no opinions besides what other
people told him to have mmm so when they
came in there you know what black people
were I remember my friend who was Korean
he came in for the first time he saw a
black person he freaked the [ __ ] out he
didn't know what the [ __ ] that was he
was like what the [ __ ] what is that what
does that person is like that's a black
person you know was African American and
he's like I've never seen like a African
America for and you know whatever
negative thought that certain Asian
people had about like the
african-american community was
they were molded to think that they
didn't have this thought about what
african-american black people were this
country mold them to think that right
but for them they were but at the end of
the day they were just worried about
feeding their families and if there was
a conversation that would have happened
they would have understood each other
right well shits going down you don't
give a [ __ ] you care about your kids and
putting food on that table that's it
yeah and there's not that conversation
in America a lot of times like here's
the thing like a lot of times in the
south it's like you know when I'm
growing up you see a lot of black
families that you know they're not
working you know you see a lot of black
you know there's a lot of violence like
I had two of my black friends got
murdered and in New Orleans over the
past 25 years 22 years so those were my
closest two black friends right so you
know you see a ton of black on black
crime and what you don't when you're
growing up in the south you know a lot
of times you don't realize that like you
know there's been generation after
generation of black families that
haven't been able to get jobs or that
haven't been able to get you know like
if your grandfather couldn't get wasn't
able to get a good job dude there's a by
the time it gets to the grandson like
you know when your grandfather could get
a parking ticket and you might not have
a good Christmas like that's a [ __ ]
that's a tight rope you know yeah and so
it's just you know there's a lot of
poverty you don't realize that when
you're growing up here especially if
you're a white person to see a lot of
black people it seem like they're not
doing anything this is always this thing
in this out like my friends you like you
know or our people would be like you
know oh there's black people to sit on
their porches and okay they're not they
don't even [ __ ] work and you know
yeah
what's like they're sitting if some of
these two people are sitting on their
porches and it's just poor people really
yeah but they're sitting on their
porches because they don't have air
conditioning yeah [ __ ] idiot it's
[ __ ] hot inside you know on sound
like so that's a reason right but you
but you don't see when you're you know
you don't see that well for three
generations somewhere in their family
has been to get a good job you know and
so at a certain point it starts to get
there starts to be a lot of apathy and
it's not just even in poor black it's in
poor white - it's like a lot of apathy
it's like well yeah you didn't see your
mom work or have or anybody you're not
gonna [ __ ] one work it's just not
part of your cult it starts to not
become part of your anything you've seen
yeah a lot of life stuff like this is
not from what I've seen growing up like
just you know
Asian Mexican you know whatever you know
there's that this is issue of this is
what why people do really well it's
generational wealth right they set their
kids up for the future a lot right from
what I've seen you know right and
they've had an advantage that you know
there's definitely been an advantage
like I saw it you know like I have
friends that would just have like rich
kids like there shouldn't be a [ __ ]
rich kid mmm
dude if my kid ever seems [ __ ] rich
bro I'm gonna [ __ ] whoop his ass for
that too man i you know what I think
about having a kid like I legitimately I
want to be the first person to jump my
kid yeah like at the age of five I mean
just give him a birthday give him sock
him in the face it's like that's like
like Daddy had to go through that [ __ ]
too
yeah like I'm like I have all these
plans of like getting like Bart and Joe
and now is gonna be you too
cuz we're gonna go into a van and we're
gonna dress up and we're gonna come to
my child to be like hey would you like
to come in for some candy yeah he comes
in we just beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
him me kick his ass out that [ __ ] is
hella Korean right I kind of like it and
then he comes back I'm like what
happened goes somebody trying to kidnap
he is like no they didn't you went in
for candy you dumbass you know I know
cuz daddy and I take off the mask
yeah daddy and then I'm one of the
background dancers I'm like it's dad
it's daddy but yeah you know it but
sometimes it's like you have to you know
it's like I don't know it's America's
tough man there's definitely but yeah
like generational wealth it's kind of
sometimes I feel like some of that stuff
it seems like it's not fair it's like
when you get to the end of your life you
know I don't know if I should all go
back into a pool but I just wish there
was a way where it gave everybody a
little bit more of a starting chance but
then sometimes if you don't have that
[ __ ] struggle bro like the struggles
what makes you
yeah the struggles what makes anything
worth any [ __ ] value you know you're
talking about like apathy too and that's
you know generational wealth you know
for me doesn't just mean money it's
knowledge yeah like knowing about
scholarships knowing about how to apply
for college these are some stuff that
immigrants don't know and people were
underprivileged they don't [ __ ] know
yeah like Joe when you talked to Joey
you should ask Joe about what he thought
about college he thought College was
rich people school right Community
College yeah that's how slow that fool
was yeah you know to me because we just
weren't taught that [ __ ] yeah you know
any mean and so these kids they were
talking about scholarships and going
into these programs I just thought oh I
just gotta get into college
I didn't know how to get there but I
knew I had to and my parents weren't a
part of this country so they don't even
know
so generational wealth has to do with
knowledge as well yeah and so the people
who had that have a leg up mmm
and so now and now it's my duty so when
I have kids and they want to go to
college I know about scholarships I know
about these routes and doors so from
here on out now we can prosper so if you
don't have that you're definitely not
gonna get that advantage more than the
money part is that knowledge right yeah
no I see that it's interesting man you
know and it's in and it's I noticed more
as I get older that it's it's not even
about race it's just about like it's
like green privilege it's just about
like class it's like because white
people had the same type of thing you
know second third generation people just
sitting around you know who you know
their grandfather didn't get a good job
so then the child didn't have any
influence to work or see an example and
then the grandchild now is just you know
is also struggling to find that you know
and you just start to see that kind of
happening it's uh you know it's it's
definitely about it's about one thing I
know things interesting you said it
isn't gonna go like you start to like
apathy happens right gentlemen apathy
but also apathy happens on the other
side when you have wealth yeah because
then you lose the [ __ ] desire you
lose the the novelty of things the
struggle though you lose there's
something like you gets I don't know
there's something that happens on that
side complacency complacency yeah cuz
it's crazy man like I like I'm I'm
better off now than I was growing up and
I know that my kids will probably grow
up in a better socio-economic
environment than I had and man that
[ __ ] makes me was super nervous you
know what's so weird though like I
already know for a fact like my kids are
gonna have better things than me and I'm
gonna hate them for it right like the
truck you little [ __ ] you know but I
bought it from you no I mean your
[ __ ] games you [ __ ] [ __ ] but uh
but I'm worried about my kid not have
another struggle you know I'm worried
about him because there's something bruh
dude it was there was something fun
running around and there still is a lot
of times and I hope
never lose it about having that chip on
your shoulder like [ __ ] these rich
people [ __ ] these you know these people
that think they know more than me [ __ ]
these people that are telling me a way
that I should be because I'm you know
they think they have some kind of
control over me just because they went
to a better school or they live in a
nicer place you know you ever realized
that a lot of the people that you tend
to like are the people who grew up with
that same background they had a similar
struggle yeah because people who have
had everything growing up I can't really
relate to them they have this different
worldview like for them
I call it them I always compared to
opening up a menu when they opened up a
menu at a restaurant they just saw what
they like to eat what I saw was the
number first it was like how many dollar
signs yeah and if it has a double digit
maybe I'm not that hungry right I mean
I'm like okay yeah how much is this
water we're gonna stay here in this
garden salads exactly I mean I'm trying
to go side items yeah hey I thought side
items were all we could eat you know I
remember the first time I started making
like a paycheck right and I ordered an
appetizer I was like yo I'm one of them
now like we'll get an app for no reason
yeah you know I'm saying I wanna you now
you know what I mean I don't I don't
just get a dish and it's split it with
my friends I get an appetizer and all
y'all eat off me
I'm eating for no reason that's [ __ ]
hilarious that's my [ __ ] um do we have
another call yeah let's get to one or
two more David thanks so much for coming
in bro no problem how'd you get so fat
as an Asian oh wow that's so cool dude
how'd you get so ugly as a white person
that's so [ __ ] funny what a [ __ ]
guy you're not seeing a sumo before yeah
but you're not you're not sumo were you
ever a big guy was a big guy you know
what I find it's so funny though it's
like somebody who does a video like that
they think that they're funny but they
don't realize how ugly God made them
yeah it's like why would you put your
face in the video when you're that
[ __ ] hideous that guy legit looks
like he kidnaps babies Oh which is a
delicacy in some places yeah which
sounds like a good name did imagine the
soft [ __ ]
a baby's ribs oh it's crazy because he
had more hair on his chin than he does
on his head that's [ __ ] wild angry yes
no because this is what it is like
people would try to roast you yeah and
I'm like you don't want to come with me
that we'll go we'll go back and forth
like with them escape with them ugly ass
rapist sunglasses which a mouth open and
[ __ ] you hit that record button and you
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
let's watch it one more time watch this
again
look at this put a dick in that mouth
right there like he did that old person
paused you know when they hit recording
they don't know what's going on yeah
let's try it once watch it one more time
here look at that like a smells breath
you feel so [ __ ] clumsy you got
straps in the back of your sunglasses I
love them and that's crazy that guy's
out of his mind
um sometimes I feel like it's I've never
dated an asian girl or been with an
asian girl sometimes I feel like they do
not like me at all because I get no vibe
from the live like at least if it's a
white girl or a black or a Latino girl I
can get a vibe a vibe from them why is
it that I cannot get that vibe from an
Asian prison justice I haven't spent
enough time random or they just kind of
keep to themselves or what is it I don't
know but I've seen a lot of like Asian
girls date white dudes now you know was
it always it looked down upon a certain
points I think it like I feel like back
in the day was like you dating a white
person yourself right yeah but what
don't you like about Asian dudes right I
mean but now it's just like cultures are
mixing now yeah yeah cultures are making
that is what it is for me I am with the
cream whoo I will propose and marry
eventually uh because number one like I
don't want to I'm not to say I don't
want to lose my culture but I connect
with there on that cultural level
because even though I am American I'm
still very Korean and I connect with
they're so hard on that yeah I mean like
mind you if I met a white girl that
could speak Korean fluently I've been on
that ass back yeah you know but I had I
didn't meet that person you know and I
met a girl who I culturally connected
with emotionally connected with it she
was Korean majority of my life I did a
Vietnamese girls Wow cuz I grew up on a
lot of it in these chicks you know yes
huh mm-hmm
I thought they were [ __ ] el fuego
there
huh did they sleep somebody's head
Vietnamese people don't sleep what I'm
not joking one of my friends told me
that man I told him it's a lie I don't
know I think Chinese people don't sleep
really that's why their restaurants
never close yeah then these restaurants
closed promptly really I don't want to
look anymore [ __ ] close the door man
[ __ ] now what about Filipino people
cuz Phillip everybody loves Filipino
people is that true
Filipino people are just like they're so
damn talented they dance they sing I
mean what don't they do man they were
they're happy they were like in the
forefront of like the gay community are
they really Asian or not they're Asian
the dark age are they an outlier you
know they're Pacific Islanders so some
like I've seen like Filipino people
correct me where they're like I'm not
Asian
I'm Pacific Islander ho but there's some
Filipino people know where Asian we're
just Pacific Islander so I guess it
depends on how you feel so yeah they're
kind of out there and that mix between
like almost like New Zealand and Asia
kind of meet or something like is that
what's going on no they're there I mean
I love Filipino people I love the food
yeah me too Oh Filipinos are great the
happy people are always usually they're
always happy - smiling people what do
they come
I know Filipino people man I love their
food man a little you know squat how
they can just sit like that I love that
I used to love their women too
cuz they would develop at the age of
three okay and so I was a kid yeah I'm
telling you man like these when you're
like a giant they were the first ones to
develop it was like the Mexican girls
and the Filipino chicks they would
always develop earlier than everybody
else but you know like Filipino people
has like Spanish blood in them yeah but
they were always the most curvaceous and
so everybody was on like every Filipino
girls jock [ __ ] damn I'm learning so
much aren't you yeah what school you
learning something from the most crude
human being on earth so don't take this
information everywhere I know I know it
says here perspective but it's dude it's
so much more than I've ever known about
like any Asian stuff and sometimes it's
like you know it's like sometimes we
just have this society where it's like
they make us feel like it's a if we ask
we're being racist and I don't [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] man yeah no you know if I
ask a questions cuz I want to [ __ ]
know you know I used to be one of those
dudes you know that you should get
offended by everything then I started
realizing how stupid I am it's like why
can't they ask they're allowed to ask
yeah it's your job to give them that
knowledge if anything else like they're
not doing anything wrong
and so for me I people get a big pass
for me a lot of the times because if
it's ignorance it's just not knowledge
right so after that just if they get
them
and they use it then we're pretty much
good because a lot of people will say
stupid [ __ ] just because they don't
[ __ ] know
yeah they don't know I I've never liked
a lot of some of the racial stuff I
never liked like I didn't I never liked
making fun of like the Asian like the
eye thing I never liked the driving
thing I don't mind making fun of cuz
that [ __ ] was baffling even though I
think second-generation Asians in
America are getting are becoming better
drivers do you notice that and I think
they're all bad I think Asian people
suck but I always thought writings
making fun of people's like some some
some of making fun of people's looks was
too easy
it just wasn't like funny to me you know
like I'm saying I you said think I just
get mad at that that asian [ __ ]
stereotype right like Asian people can't
drive and then I got my driver's license
and I was like oh [ __ ] I can't drive you
know and I was like oh [ __ ] I suck at
this you know I mean like oh we're on a
spectrum right so either we're really
doping it like yeah or we're just like
the Chinese lady who's getting her
groceries as trans like going over four
lanes for no reason yeah and I'm the
Chinese lady I have this theory that
Asians aren't good in motion that's my
theory
except for martial arts done but martial
art is in motion but it's also very like
like II WA Jeep like Asian people hide
in the ground to fight like the flying
once they get in the plane they crashed
the plane like you know what I'm saying
like and I don't mean it in a bad way I
just had this theory that like an Asian
person from a solitary place extremely
effective the most effective you know
what an karate is kind of from a
solitary place in a way you know it's
like you're kind of you then move out
but it's very stationary at first but
Asian people in motion you know what it
is is this that I think we're so [ __ ]
next level that when you went to China
right there's no real street rules
people just what if there's space you
driving it yeah and that's how it is in
Vietnam people said oh yeah Viet Nam's
crazy yeah so we're so [ __ ] next
level we don't need lines we just
intuitively know and so they take those
same rules and apply it to America but
it doesn't apply here like you have to
followed right there's more lanes it's
kind of like New York like a red lights
suggestive right you know I mean like
when you're in New York you see like
people pass Reds they're like no it's
just a suggestion yeah I did notice that
there's so many people in China that
when they move you think there's no way
this is all gonna work out and it's so
much more intuition
it's next level bro it really you know
that's really interesting
and it's I think it's a wave that starts
to happen in a mental telepathy that
starts to happen in a connectivity that
happens when there's so many people and
you're that close together to certain we
just figure out how to [ __ ] move
together like my girlfriend got t-boned
by this Chinese lady that just came from
China not too long her explanation is so
[ __ ] funny and she has a dash cam so
recorded everything and this lady comes
up she [ __ ] turns on unprotected and
just smashes into my girlfriend's car
right like what the [ __ ] she goes she
goes she goes looks at my girl she goes
what's your problem and she's like
what's your problem but as she's like
literally explaining what she did even
though it's wrong but she thinks it's
right so when she reported it to the
insurance she thought she was defending
herself but she was just incriminating
herself while she thought she was like
Ryan's in there an insurance adjuster
was like yeah we pretty easy she just
admitted to everything she did and it
was so [ __ ] funny she goes no it's my
turn and she goes well how do you know
that she goes I just came here from
China and I just took the test so I know
the rules better than you Wow and that
was her reasoning I'm psyched dude this
is wild in and she just got t-boned it's
all recorded it's [ __ ] amazing it's
unbelievable man the dark arts David so
we appreciate you coming in where can
people check out [ __ ] we'll put a link
and stuff to it you could check it out
on Netflix or buy it on blu-ray
yeah about it and check me out on
youtube comm slash Dave so comedy mr.
grant man Twitter yeah well sure I would
love to do some sketches some sometime
again do something like that yeah we
could do anything bro like I got my
channel now is just me walking around
being stupid you know we could think of
some stupid [ __ ] we should just do a
whole episode about finding out what why
people do versus Asian people dude I
would love to uh what about the yin yin
in y'all yeah yeah every kind of funny
that should have you [ __ ] dope is
reviewing some veigar is figuring
something out you know if I ever come
back a stand-up comic just let me open
open up for you man no I don't know
about all that but I know I did I'd be
honored for uh
you can find him on he's your not your
Jay King who's regular right is that how
they claim you in their claim you all
kind of started it together huh and I
have my own thing in general so I'm not
trying to run the channel right but I'll
be a part of it yeah you know if you can
see like my role in that thing is
literally to facilitate conversation
yeah I'll talk about anything and
everything it's fun man you guys really
it's so funny man that I would go
to a place of you know to you know just
in a place of different culture for me
you know it's like most of my friends
are just comedians but to go in a place
where you know it's just different
ethnicities that don't hang out every
day and the [ __ ] and that would be the
place I kind of broaden my horizon and
be like man this is you know you can
make fun of whatever you know it's just
no lows bar you know if people get their
feelings hurt like look I'm not saying
I'm trying to be an [ __ ] or anything
but in the name of comedy I'm still
working with thin boundaries yeah I know
when things go too far you know but I
can always talk about my personal
experience you know sometimes when we
tell stories you know I think like as
comedians too we collect stories and we
observe a lot mm-hmm there's a lot of
these kids don't understand that they're
like there's no way all this stuff
happened it's like it did but you just
don't observe your life like we do right
you know and we collect stories and it
sticks in our head because everything's
a bit a sketch or something to write
about right like the way I'm seeing
everything the way it's even coming into
my head is a little bit more of like oh
how can this be a story not just like
what's going on exactly yeah
it's interesting man I love thank you
for coming in and sitting here and just
thinking about it and you know teaching
us a little bit about you know just
different [ __ ] man oh yeah man anytime
dude it's fun David so ladies and
gentlemen thank you David
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of mind I found I can defeat
it in my bones thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]